على الصعيد الميداني تطورات متلاحقه في
منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ حيث تنذر
التحركات العسكريه باتجاه الاوضاع نحو
تصعيد محتمل فمن مدينه بوسان الساحليه في
كوريا الجنوبيه انطلقت حامله الطائرات
الامريكيه باتجاه بحر اليابان حيث تجري
مناورات بحريه ثلاثيه امريكيه يابانيه
كوريه جنوبيه تهدف الى تعزيز شراكه
الاستراتيجيه في مواجهه التهديد القادم من
كوريا الشماليه وقد دعا زعيم كوريا
الشماليه كيم جونغ اون تزامنا مع ذلك الى
زياده الترسانه النوويه لبلاده قائلا انه
يجب ان تكون مستعده تماما لاستخدامها في
اي وقت وقد دخلت روسيا بدورها على خط
المواجهه باعلانها اختبار صاروخ صاروخ
كروز فرد صوتي مضاد للسفن في بحر اليابان
يبلغ مداه 100 كيلومتر وقبل ذلك ارسلت
طائرتين مقاتلتين استراتيجيتين للتحليق
فوق المنطقه